back here on the internet mell in
today's PC environment would you be able
to make the same movies you wrote and
produced in the 70s not at all
really mmm you come on first of all what
is we had a screening of Blazing Saddles
and the man who is in charge of Warner
Brothers at that time who shall be
nameless dead Ashley I said dragged me
into the manager's office at the Affco
embassy and said I'm gonna give you some
notes about the movie you know it was
like his studio at the N word out
farting of course out punishing the
[ __ ] on shady punching the horse uh
punching an old lady yeah she said have
you ever seen such for the whole movie
out like so I would have had about 14
minutes of movie left you get up but you
certainly did open the way from a lot
more farting yeah I get I mean there is
so much farting pooping and throwing up
and move yeah I hate all of it
really there's nothing less money or
more gross than [ __ ] and fart at movies
I mean it you know it was like the first
time it was funny it was like when
Muhammad Ali bragged it was great it was
the first time now we've seen it a
million times sorry I started it yes you
should now get out of here I'm good why
I brought you here so I've just eyes you
for starting that horrible dread alright
should personal drone use be regulated
by the government
ah good question a drone hit the White
House lawn this week almost hit an
intruder
what do you think drones you'd be good
my life to that Lauren it's interesting
now that drones are flying over the
White House that people realize it's not
something that they want happening over
their home um they declared the
Superbowl and no drone zone yeah so
there's a bit of irony in this in terms
of my own program that's happening in
other countries um this is the last
bastion of privacy we can talk to each
other right and nobody will listen
because you don't get a rating so we get
tough that's it that's a big line it is
a big line we get a good writing that's
Ryan here well I mean of course it
should be regulated and while we're at
it we should stop the drone killing
program probably do patron kill yeah
yeah it probably creates more problems I
mean I think we create a few enemies
that way yeah yes we do in fact one of
the Charlie headbow killers said he was
you know really yeah was I think or
maybe was Gitmo what but you know
terrorists have said it's either drone
strikes killed my wedding party yeah or
Gitmo I mean these obviously are great
recruiting tools that's why he keeps
saying get out of there and we won't
create them blah blah blah okay so uh
representative Castro as someone who
sits on the cybersecurity caucus what
can you tell us about the government's
effort to protect us from cyber
terrorism well well you know we've seen
out of the coin right yeah I mean we've
seen the government get hacked both
domestically and interests again
international folks we've seen our
private businesses get hacked so the
government's got to do a better job of
working with private industry to make
sure to make it harder for these folks
to tap into networks to do what happened
at places like Target and and other I
think Home Depot maybe in other places
where people's personal information was
stolen but but honestly we still have a
long way to go to reach that level of
cooperation and there is some mistrust I
think on the side of private industry
with the government I feel like we'll
never get to the point where we can feel
secure in an email or a text I mean did
you know do you text you I am I'm what's
called an assistant
she's she's brilliant she's mad she
tweets from AG texts Louise no she
doesn't we do she tweets well like
sometimes I don't know what that we were
you right I didn't know you were on
Twitter you're onto it I'm too I'm big
you're bigger
you should be big on Twitter yeah I'm
gonna follow you say something about
that I mean I think the NSA uses a lot
of resources actually they're building
backdoors into the internet and they
should use their money to like make it
secure because all of our information
needs to be protected
but when CENTCOM gets hacked right and
it right nothing actually that was very
devastating it wasn't a national
security threat but if they can get into
centcom's computers they could probably
get into anyone elses computers that
they want to get into okay who is they
hackers anybody in their underwear well
it can be a government like North Korea
yeah or it can be a teenager yeah we
don't know yeah of course that's who
knows all this [ __ ] is teenagers I think
no it's true and my assistant they go
yeah they know what does the panel make
up the latest friction between the Prime
Minister of Israel and the Obama
administration well yes that's a big
political brouhaha John Boehner invited
Netanyahu to speak without even telling
the president um where you stand on
Israel Mel are you Jewish you you think
that you oh yeah I meant to read your
bio before the show but the word is the
responses only but I do you think
Netanyahu will will sit next to Boehner
unless he's really has a great makeup
person before he's gonna well he's gonna
he says I want to be orange - hey
what do you think of that I think I
think the president ought to be the one
inviting another head of state to speak
to the Congress address the congressman
address it seems aging very new I know I
don't feel like we've ever nobody ever
really did done before it just sort of n
run around the White House with foreign
policy it kind of I mean what happened
to that stops at the water's edge and
you know did the Dixie Chicks said
something bad about Bush in London and
they were like super duper traitors just
cuz they said Bush sucks you saw it's in
the province of the State Department
that you're not being in Congress
president you tell the State Department
of State Department should write an
invitation I mean and he's really
protocol right yeah cuz you got the
aralia ambassador right I think
congressman saying actually this is all
bein as fault this was not Netanyahu's
fault we thought that there told the
White House honestly is the line coming
out it really got boiling that this is
backfire yeah and it's also complicating
Israeli politics because their elections
are so close also and there had been a
policy about the United States and the
president not meeting with the Israeli
ambassador idiom any foreign if I'm
their head of state or any head of state
when the elections were coming up no so
all right final question your Israel
said don't help me de Boehner in don't
help me I'm good don't know how the
Trump yes I'm fine out here I don't need
any work the mountain it's okay Mel what
is your most embarrassing moments in
show business
besides this show I know you were gonna
say that
notice true I many years ago well I
think I was twelve
I'm not sure yeah I was on a show called
uh I forget I say or I guess or I
something a game show yeah game showing
bill Cullen a brilliant Yahoo you know
the yeah you had that crew cut and those
big glasses and he was fast and he was
good he was really maybe the best your
name show show host that ever lived a
low bar who's behind a podium always
behind a podium all the time and at the
end of the show and we all had fun Judy
Meade was my partner
and I think we won you know was a very
exciting you know waste of time anyway
it reads so we did did this show you
were the celebrity life is always thumbs
the celebrity and at the end of the show
bill Colin comes from around his Cody
around his podium and and he says Mel
it's you know it's such a he said
governor Mel it's such a pleasure to
meet you oh and I said oh he's doing
Jerry Lewis oh so I said oh well I'll do
Jackson big I did the same thing and he
wasn't no it was weird because in the
end he hugged me and he said son of a
[ __ ] you're the only one who had the
guts to do me he says what a relief he
says your Unni had tears in his eyes I
said I wanted a I wanted to do that for
you
thank you very much ladies
what isn't
don't treasure